[Music]
St dear prime minister I am very glad to
welcome you to Brussels as we celebrate
50 years of diplomatic relations between
Bangladesh and the European Union in all
these years we have built a solid
partnership and now we will take it to
the next level because in a time of
global turbulence the European Union is
glad to be able to count on its
longstanding Partners as they can count
on us
so first we are relaunching negotiations
on a new partnership and cooperation
agreement and this is great
news second this new chapter in our
relationship will be underpinned by new
Investments under global gateway we just
discussed it we are about to sign two
investment packages the first one is a
renewable energy package more than 400
million euros boost the green transition
in your country and that's good for the
climate and it is also good for job
creation
locally Global gate will will invest
close to 1 billion euros in Bangladesh
and we will not stop there we're working
together with the eiib to improve the
connectivity in your country we
discussed that too from your Port
infrastructure to Railways and digital
infrastructure there many great projects
that we have in the
pipeline the second investment package
we will sign is our annual action plan
for
2023 it's an investment road map of 70
million EUR in your public
administration and in
employment investment in skills and
education and green construction so this
new chapter in our partnership is
starting off really well thank you very
much again for being here in Brussels
thank
you thank you Madame President uh we
just had a Frank exchange of views on
Bangladesh EU relations we reaffirmed
our shared values of democracy human
rights and the rule of
law this year marks the 50th anniversary
of Bangladesh EU partnership we are
pleased that the EU is now Bangladesh's
largest trading partner the eu's
everything but arms schemed contributed
immensely to Bangladesh's social
economic
development I recall formalizing these
Arrangements during my first terms in
office in
2000 I hope that the EU will offer GSP
plus to Bangladesh to support our
development following our LDC graduation
in
2026 Bangladesh welcomes the eu's global
gateway initiative in a few minutes we
are going to witness the signing of a
number of agreements including a 350
million euro Finance contract with
European Investment Bank we appreciate
your interest in partner
partnering with us on CL climate action
and renewable
energy I thank the EU for its
humanitarian assistance for the 1.2
million ringas being temporarily
sheltered by
Bangladesh this solution to the rohinga
crisis lies in their safe and
sustainable return to their Homeland in
Myanmar and I urge the EU to remain
engaged for an early durable solution to
to this
crisis with Madame President I we have
renewed our commitment to promote
workers rights and as well as safe and
regular migration I flagged our interest
in partnering on resource and Innovation
to find solution to some of our local
challenges we are planning for a future
partnership with the EU focusing more on
strategic elements
I am happy that we have agreed to launch
a negotiation on a partnership and
cooperation agreement very soon this
would open a new chapter in our
excellent bilateral relations I thank
you Madame President thank you very much
and thank you
[Applause]
all will